so there I was building a great
responsive UI when it hit me
multi-window is going to change
everything well okay maybe not
everything but there are some special
considerations when it comes to building
and designing for split screen
multimedia for just become even more
important when users can resize your app
check out our other video on the basics
of building a responsive UI and the
patterns you can use to adapt your
layout to changes in size thankfully
building a responsive app for your
existing users covers almost all of the
configurations you'll see in split
screen multi
but there are two relatively unique
configurations you might consider when
designing your app first is the sixteen
by nine layout on mobile devices in
portrait here it's important to keep in
mind the heavily constrained vertical
space make sure users can actually see
some content between fixed navigation
elements like an expanded app bar and
bottom nav bar the other is of 34 point
15% layout on tablets here you have an
extremely wide aspect ratio on portrait
devices a technique we found useful is
to start with your mobile device layouts
and stretch them to fit this new
configuration once you have a fully
responsive UI now comes the fun part
taking advantage of multi window by
default multi window is enabled and it's
enabled for your entire task stack it
means if your route activities supports
multi-window every activity started from
that root activity also needs to support
multi window this also applies to any
exported activities you have they'll
inherit the multi window capabilities of
the other app and therefore should
always support multi window now when in
multi window mode the minimal size is
220 by 220 DP
you can use min height and min width to
set a larger minimum size but in
split-screen multiverse can still resize
you smaller you'll just get cropped off
and no one likes an inaccessible button
so try removing as much as possible to
get down to that minimum size now beyond
the first priority of does my app run in
multi window mode should come as no
surprise the best experience here for
users is a fast smooth transition from
the biggest screen sizes down to the
smallest and vice-versa if your tablet
and mobile layouts are very similar you
may find this to already be the case the
important thing to remember is you don't
want the user to feel lost when they
resize your app if your layouts are
vastly different don't change between
them instead try scaling your tablet UI
down to fit the smaller space that way
your app will be consistent on all sizes
keep in mind that just like any other
configuration change the default
behavior is to kill and recreate your
activity when it's resized reloading all
of your resources for you
assuming you save your state using on
stave instance state and use loaders or
other techniques to keep data across
configuration changes this should be
really fast however if you want to take
total control and reload only the exact
things you need you can handle
configuration changes yourself by adding
the config changes attribute to your
activity then applying the changes in on
configuration changed not for the faint
heart though test thoroughly now if
you're a fully immersive experience like
a game I get it maybe you want to
disable multi window if you aren't
targeting API 24 adding Android
orientation or Android immersive to your
manifest will disable multi window and
of course the new resizable activity
attribute can be added to your
application or to your route activity to
opt out of multi window check out the
blog post linked in the description for
all the details and some other patterns
like relying on edge swipes
should be avoided to best support
multi-window build a great responsive UI
build a great multi window experience
but most importantly just continue to
build better apps